will it make you not want to go back to
medicine and i will say
hell yes it did for me i would just say
it's a bit of a regret i lost on that
said what the hell am i supposed to do
which was the case for me just as hard
to convince yourself to go back than it
is to convince yourself to take the gap
year which is saying something hi if
you're new to this channel my name is
elizabeth and i am usually a medical
student in london last year i
interrupted my studies and took a gap
year i have applied for an interruption
from studies from university which means
that i will not be going back to
university this august and ever since i
get so many questions asked on how the
experience has been whether i regret it
and all the pros and cons and how to
manage things in this time so i thought
i would compile all your questions
together and create a video now all the
questions that were asked to me were
around regrets so i've divided this
video into two parts the first will be
the regrets or potential regrets and how
i address these um in terms of my
personal gap year and the second part
will be the huge benefits or the things
that i think are um that i don't regret
doing this gap year for one major thing
i want to say before i start this video
is that everything that i benefit from
or suffer from during my gap year is a
hundred percent due to the very specific
conditions of my life that i am in and
honestly just due to my luck so i just
want to say everything that i am
explaining or describing please take
with a pinch of salt and they're
definitely not recommendations just a
very very raw and perhaps too
transparent exploration into how this
journey has been for me so just for a
bit of context before i get started i
have finished my three years of medical
school i am currently taking an
interruption gap year and that means
that i will have two more years left
when i return back to medical school
next year hopefully let's see so yeah
that is the stage of a medical training
that i am at the moment and during this
gap year i have been potentially working
on quite a few things i'm a strategy
consultant most of the time i also work
on this youtube channel i have a few
newsletters a podcast of my own and also
i just launched a course of my own so
there's quite a few things going on
there in the background so it hasn't
necessarily been a lot of time off but
it's definitely been a break from my
studies so let's jump in firstly the
main theme that came out of why to
regret a gap year and why potentially
regret gap year was the idea of taking
time out and a lot of panic of letting
time rush past me and getting older and
all of this stuff this was i think a
huge issue for me to start with medical
school so i am a older student i took
three gap years before starting
university anyway and these were not by
choice i really really wanted to go to
university immediately after my high
school however due to very specific
conditions at the time i had to keep
deferring my place in university for
three years so i was already very very
proud of the idea of my life is running
past me my peers are graduating my peers
are getting married my
peers are in work already and earning so
much money and buying houses and i'm
just sitting here waiting to start
university i think that eventually this
does tend to fade a bit when i was first
considering my gap year this was one of
the most acute things that was on my
mind at the time so last summer when i
was really considering my gap year i was
just counting the numbers of how old i
would be when i would graduate and then
just thinking oh can i afford this like
extra space in my life and just pause
everything and everything's just going
to take a year longer why would i do
this let's just power through and
there's this huge notion of powering
through and getting it finished and
my perspective has completely shift on
that right now so so so much i think
that
that is absolute [ __ ] i think that
there is genuinely no rush because where
are you trying to get to i think very
very often especially in medicine
there's this view of because you have so
many milestones that you need to hit
like there's the next exam and then
there's the next exam and your next
portfolio and your training pathway and
everything is divided into two years
plus four years plus five years so it
seems as though these things are just
milestones that you need to reach and
tick box exercises that you need to do
these are very what i like to use this
is book that i read on finite infinite
games it's a very finite game it's you
do something and you complete it while i
think life is more of an infinite game
if you just take a step back and what i
did is i took a step back and i looked
at the whole perspective and i was like
where am i trying to go and there was
nowhere specific i was trying to go i'm
not trying to reach a certain thing to
me there's no inherent pleasure in kind
of graduating and becoming a doctor and
oh my god i did this and then oh my god
i finished my junior doctor training and
oh my god i'm a consultant now that
necessarily doesn't give me too much
pleasure it did at one point of my life
that imagining that but now it's rather
the point of my life is for me to be
healthy and happy and at peace and
whatever that looks like a year here two
years there graduating at 35 maybe i do
an extra year and then i take a gap year
and i do an extra year it doesn't matter
it really really doesn't matter to me i
think that there is no rush and i need
to let go of this grasping onto things
not only in medicine but in so many
different aspects of my life and letting
go of this control has been a very good
exercise for me to kind of be a bit more
at peace with where i'm going so i think
it was just the perspective shift of
where am i trying to go and why does
this number matter what if you were
suddenly told that i i don't know um
actually there was an issue with your
birth certificate and you were born
three years ago would you have a like
phoebe and friends when she told that
hey um the sister told her that she was
a year older and she was like oh my god
i'm already 30. that was such a
difficult situation for her but imagine
that was for you in the end of the day
the numbers just don't matter there is
no rush to get anywhere you could be a
year older a year younger
i think letting go of the number game is
a very important exercise to do as soon
as possible because at some point
because of society we get uh we start
seeing threes in front of things and
fours in front of things and thinking
that oh my god time has passed but that
was a very wrong long long ramble
already oh my god this is going to be a
long video in the sense of yep these
things just don't matter and the sooner
i realize that the better for me and
i've fully embraced it there's no rush
it's not about the numbers this feels
right right now or i need to do this
right now there's no choice let's just
do it and embrace it and move on the
next question that came up a lot and was
related to this was the panic of my
friends graduating first or having no
friends next year and
i kind of cheated on this because after
the third year in medical school the
majority of people will intercalate
which means that they will take a year
out to do another degree and then they
will return back to university so a lot
of the people that i was in my year with
have chosen this a lot haven't
especially because a lot of my friends
tend to be postgraduates so they already
have a degree so they just chose to
continue a lot of them will now be
graduating a year earlier but a lot of
them will be at the same stage with me
having said that even if no one was
there again it was so important for me
to take this gap at this time and i
really felt that it was the right thing
so
i don't think friendships are dependent
on kind of the situation that you are in
as much if there are true friendships if
that makes sense and especially in
medicine you don't get any choice you
get placed in different hospitals across
different sites and even when you're
sitting in exams very often you don't
see your friends so i don't think there
would be a big difference i'm still in
contact with my friends so i don't think
it would be an issue in that sort of way
yes
sometimes i feel perhaps actually when i
see my friends graduate next year i'll
feel like oh that could have been me but
um for now i just feel that that's not a
main issue and yeah i don't worry about
that as much the next question i got
asked a lot was on not having a purpose
and purpose in general i think this is
only an issue if the majority of your
purpose or your purpose comes from
medicine and suddenly that's not there
and you think what the hell am i
supposed to do which was the case for me
because so much of my life was built
around medicine and
when i thought that i wasn't doing this
anymore for a moment i did have the
sense of oh my god what now where does
this go and what if i don't return what
will happen um i think it's a dangerous
place to be but it's a very healthy
exercise to do in the long term and
this is potentially something that i
would recommend lightly to people who
are in medicine to kind of i think just
even realize for a second how much of
your identity and self-worth is tied
around this thing that you're doing
because you never want that to be just
one thing i think um i got told this by
a doctor once and it made me cry
um it was a one-to-one that i had with a
doctor and she she just sat me down she
said elizabeth you are so much more than
your accomplishments i don't know why it
was the first time at the age of 24 that
someone had told this to me but it
really hit me so hard and i just spent
so much time thinking about this because
i realized there was almost nothing
there apart from my accomplishments that
determined my self-worth almost i think
leaving medicine this was very very
healthy because it made me realize that
no actually you have value as a person
in your own right and
these are just things that you do and
you might do them very well and they may
help other people that's fine but that
doesn't
add or take away from who you are as a
person because you are valuable in your
own right so i think it's a very healthy
exercise that i've done in trying to
find self-worth and value and purpose
outside of medicine which i've
definitely found now and it's much more
healthier than to make an informed
decision of kind of setting boundaries
again it's not it's not displacing worth
it's not that now my worth is kind of oh
am i a good strategy am i good at my day
job it's not that it's elizabeth is she
good is she okay is she happy and these
are just things that i do and i think i
only managed to fully do this after
leaving medicine so i think this was a
huge benefit and not a regret definitely
that i had in terms of taking a gap year
the next question is justifying it to
others this is so difficult i actually
have not shared the reasons that i took
a gap year online yet and i think at
some point i might i'm just not ready to
talk about it still now it's deeply
personal um and i don't know what the
format would look like necessarily or
how to explain these things or how much
emotion can you show online um so i'm
not too sure about that and when it
comes to people asking
it depends on how well i know the people
so the closest people in my life and the
people at my job kind of know the
reasons specifically that i took a gap
year um because it is important
information to them and i feel
comfortable sharing it if i'm close to
someone um i think in in my day-to-day
life i'm really really open so if i feel
comfortable in a situation i'll very
easily say what were the reasons that i
took a gap year um however it's not
something that i've shared online and in
terms of justifying it to people i don't
if someone asked me why did you take a
gap year because i wanted to um and
no one can say much to that and this
kind of ties onto the next one which is
regrets that terms of parents reaction
um
my gap year was very very spontaneous so
i thought about it seriously one morning
by lunch i had decided that i was going
to do it and then i
sent an email to my university and then
i called my mom and dad and then the
next day the university confirmed it so
the turnaround was literally 24 hours
for this whole thing from my parents
having no clue that i was even
considering this to me going hey um i'm
not going back to uni in august so that
was very scary i think my mum understood
it more i think my dad was very scared
because i think my dad
was concerned that i wouldn't go back
which is something i'm going to address
a bit later um but i think my dad was a
bit concerned about that especially
throughout my gap you're always asking
me are you going to go back and um i
think when it comes to parents
when you are a certain age and if you
have a sort of a good relationship with
your parents it's easy enough to say i
realize your concern and recognize where
their concern or anxiety is coming
around because if they're having a
highly emotional reaction um it's likely
because
they are assuming that you are not
considering things that you actually
have considered so i think telling that
to them and saying hey um you know tell
me what's concerning you right now are
you worried because i am not listening
to you or you think that i'm not
listening to you are you worried because
i'm doing this to spot you or go against
what you wanted are you worried because
i think i haven't considered the risks
and kind of exploring them with your
parents and saying actually i have
considered this and i have considered
this and that and that but in the end of
the day if you say but i need this and
this is which is what i said is that i i
need this and this will make me happier
and healthier and i really really need
to do this right now um there's very
little that a parent can say
i think sometimes to you saying that no
but i need this and this is what what i
need and i've decided it and i think
that was a situation that i wasn't with
my parents again things are very
different because i live away from my
parents and i am kind of financially
independent so a lot of these things
don't muddy up the situation but i think
it was difficult to break it to my
parents i don't think it's something
that they expected and um but at the
moment i think they are just
happy either way i think my mom doesn't
want me to go back to medical school but
my dad does so yeah there's that with
parents the next question is such a
legitimate one and that's the panic of
for getting things in medicine this i
would say a hundred percent is true i do
have a bit of panic around this because
i do realize i have forgotten so so much
i think that
i don't have a specific plan for this in
place just because the next few months
of my life are going to be extremely
intense but maybe in two months i will
start revising again and that's
something i might do online maybe do
some live streams of questions or just
do some live stream study with me that
would be something quite cool i think
but i do need to i think revise quite a
bit more and do more work when i start
again
in terms of catching up having said that
because i took three gap years between
my high school and university i didn't
actually find that even in three years i
had lost a lot of information compared
to my peers um i was actually reading a
lot of medical stuff in the meantime
though so maybe there was a bit of that
but um i think that we
overestimate how much we forget and that
if the foundations are solid then very
very easily you can catch up with these
things again and then it depends on
where your kind of pride lies i guess i
think for me in medicine this shifted
very fast in the beginning i was very
much oh i want to know all the details i
want to be that girl who just knows you
know that pathway it knows that the name
of that enzyme and that's completely
changed now where i'm like oh i don't
actually care about that stuff i am much
more interested in the important uh the
things that i consider to be essential
in medicine which is how you deal with
patients and your patient care and your
communication and understanding the
basic things that are applicable in
hospital in real life and the very
important things because i've realized
that even though i spent so much energy
learning these small facts they always
fade so fast in a few months definitely
in a few years they'll all be forgotten
while the rest are the things that
remain there and i think would make me
likely a better clinician so i think in
that sense yes i'm sad that i'm probably
not going to be the brightest person in
any room in medicine when i go back but
um at the same time i would just say
it's a bit of a regret and a loss in
that sense but not enough for me to
regret my whole gap year the next one
was setting goals during your gap year
this is interesting
the spontaneity with which i took mine
meant that there was not a lot of time
for goal-setting and also i'm not a
goal-setting person i just don't like
goals in general and therefore i had
none but this was not out of character
for me so if you're the sort of person
who likes goal setting i guess you can
set something for your gap year that
would be great i'm the sort of person
who hates specific goals so i don't set
them in general so yeah i didn't set any
and i'm very happy with that situation
oh this is a very good one did you make
a pros and cons list i did but it was
impossible and
the reason for that is there's just so
much unknowns if you if you do a pros
and cons list for leaving medicine and
staying in medicine
it's so hard because you don't know
where things will go you don't know how
you will feel in the future i don't know
what i'm making decisions for
a person that i don't know i don't know
if i'm going to be in five years just
like i made a decision for myself now
when i first got into medical school i
would be making a decision for elizabeth
in five years if i left medical school i
took a gap year i just don't know who
the hell that girl is and what she wants
and who she is and i just i've realized
that there's just no point there
especially with the unknown unknowns and
with even known unknown so i'm like i
don't know how i'm going to feel and i
don't know actually what my experience
of medical school would be and how much
free time i will have and if i can
balance these things i just had no
answers for these so in the end of the
day i scrapped the pros and cons last
and i just went with my gut and i think
that's the best thing to do in this case
at least for me it was an emotional
decision it was not a um
it was not a pros and cons list because
well actually if it was a president
condolence i think i would have to leave
anyway but there's a part of me that
felt oh you can get over these things
while in medical school you don't need
to leave medicine so i don't think i was
being rational with my pros and cons
anyway so for me it was an emotional
decision i thought yep
actually i'm going to stop this now so
that's how i did made the decision the
last one on regrets of a gap year is the
one very very legitimate one
is
will it make you not want to go back to
medicine and i will say
hell yes it did for me and this was the
most scary thing i think and this is
one reason why i would potentially warn
against a gap year but then again if you
take a gap year and you realize you
don't want to do something then maybe
it's not the right thing for you but
anyway in the beginning i missed
hospital and i missed medicine but that
only lasted for a few months and then
after that i thought oh there's so much
going on in my life and there's so many
other things happening and
very funnily um a hundred percent of
people in the medical field especially
trained doctors and the more senior they
are the more they would tell me don't go
back just don't make the mistake of
going back just stay away um it's like
it's so good that you have other things
that you can do and you enjoy don't go
back and then it was either the people
who are very junior in medicine so early
medical students or it was people who
were not in medicine who were saying oh
you have to go back it's so good for you
like my parents for example so that was
a very interesting observation i had and
equally i felt that
oh there's so many things i'm doing now
that i enjoy is it worth completing
medical school do i still want to be a
doctor at some point um i think a gap
year will definitely do that to you
especially if you enjoy your gap year if
you find something that it feels like
it's your calling or if you find
something that you deeply enjoy outside
of medicine it becomes so difficult to
convince yourself to go back especially
in my case where if i would leave i
would still have a diploma in medical
sciences because i've completed the
three-year degree so
i don't know i think this one is very
very risky in my case i think i've
decided that i am going to go back but i
would just say it's just as hard to
convince yourself to go back than it is
to convince yourself to take the gap
year which is saying something because
convincing myself to take that gap year
was definitely one of the hardest things
i've ever done um and yeah so it's very
very difficult both ways i think one of
my friends mark his friend said this to
me
where he said don't take a gap here just
just leave because if you take a gap
year you're never going to go back and i
think it is so hard
to do that um that's a slight warning
that i do give if you take a gap year
during university now the last part of
this video is going to be the pros and
the things that i absolutely don't
regret doing in my gap year that i think
are incredible and the first one was
that it gave me so much time to sort out
my mental health um i've been in a lot
of therapy in my gap year and i've been
dealing with a lot of issues that i have
racked up my whole life especially
during lockdown um and i think my gap
year gave me the space to do this
without
so many deadlines i did have deadlines
because i still had a job the whole time
but not the medical deadlines and the
medical guilt um that i would have it
was very difficult to do these things
while being in medical school while
being outside of medical school i think
it's grown me so much in terms of my
mental health and my my peace and my
kind of self-exploration and
understanding so i think that this has
been such a good space to do this
absolutely would recommend for that
reason the second reason i really delved
in already was finding yourself outside
of medicine i think doing these other
things have uncovered so much of me as a
person that i don't think i would have
ever found if i stayed in medicine only
and also it's opened up my eyes to
specific aspects of medicine that i can
find elsewhere in the end of the day my
favorite part of medicine is sitting
down in front of a patient
that is why i'm doing the job um it's
not for the admin i don't think it is
for anyone it's not about running around
in hospital um it's not
it's just for also for the banter
between doctors and kind of the
connections that you get in working in a
team so teamwork and also
being in front of a patient and getting
to help someone and these are the two
things that i love the most about
medicine but the latter i kind of find
in consulting and in helping people and
in coaching and having calls with people
and helping them grow in other aspects
of their life i have found
doing that to an extent never never
comparable to medicine because health i
think is on a different level but that
sort of pleasure is the same that i find
in that sort of job while otherwise
working in a team are things that you
can get quite easily in many many
different jobs so i found that i can in
a way engineer a sort of career that is
a hundred percent just my favorite parts
of medicine but lacks the reward which
is the frustrating part so but anyway i
think finding and testing out different
waters i've grown so much in my
knowledge because before my knowledge
was 100 just medicine based and customer
service based and now i know so much
about branding and marketing and
business and finance and customer
profiling and um online courses
especially which is a super nice thing
to know about and knowledge management
and the internet and social media so
there's so much that i've learned
outside of medicine with a lot of the
skills that medical training has taught
me that has been extremely extremely
valuable so that's something that i
really really like and i think even
though i've really expanded the range of
things i can potentially do in my future
and the range of expertise that i have
at the same time i think by diluting my
self-worth from just medicine it's just
gone to nothing and it's just gone to me
being and i think oh i have all these
options now which give me a lot more
calmness because i think at least for me
i always thought that it was either
medicine or nothing and i would never be
good at anything else and i think
finding and seeing that i can
potentially enjoy and be just as good as
if not better at other things then that
makes me very i think happy and it's a
very liberating way to live my life from
now on the third reason and of course
this is personal is um growing my
youtube channel and my pod starting my
podcast um i would not have started my
podcast i think if i was back in medical
school although my channel might have
grown more because medical content does
tend to do well so i don't know about
that one but i think these two have been
very very fun um creating kind of being
a creator again as an adult was
something that i thought i wouldn't be
able to do
after i kind of grew up and didn't have
the extra time in medicine so this has
been really really fun for me and lastly
it kind of gave me a little reset button
um to take some separation between
everything that i was doing and approach
it with a different eye and also gaining
these other skills put me in a position
of empowerment where it was no longer
the need of oh i have these loans i need
to continue this i've committed to this
but rather going okay what are the
reasons you want to do this do you
actually want to do this do you want to
try it out um and everything becomes
more of a let's try this out and see how
it goes and life is long there is no
rush and there is no final destination
to get to but rather you just enjoy
things for what they are in the moment
and you take value from what they are in
the moment i think the biggest chef for
me has been thinking that i always
thought that i would be proud of myself
when i graduated medical school and
there was nothing to be proud of
especially if i left that would just be
embarrassing like the whole thing that i
did in medicine would be a failure and
an embarrassment and that is not the
case at all it's not a failure it's not
an embarrassment i'm so proud and happy
now when i look back at the things that
i did that even if i never go back or i
never continue my studies that's
something amazing that i did in medicine
and i'm really really happy about it and
i don't need to wait to finish things to
enjoy them and the same way when i go
back hopefully it will be fun by value
and virtue of being there it will be fun
because i know i chose to be there and i
have these other options it will be fun
because i know i can shape my life in a
very empowered way and in a way that i
enjoy and i'll be fun because hopefully
i'll be much healthier when i go back to
medicine so yeah that was my view on the
gap year yes i don't regret it in the
slightest i think it is one of the best
decisions i have made in my life and i
would 100
um oh no wait i can't say that and
i would potentially recommend it to
many many many people having said this i
asked two three four four of my friends
who have taken gap years and all of them
said it was the best decision they've
ever made so i'm i know that's not a
huge sample size but i get to meet
someone who regrets their gap year
everyone that i've met just raves about
it so much so i think do your research
ask the people around you do some
rational thinking into why you're doing
it how you can fill in this time and how
you will feel yourself and what support
system you have in place and do you have
people around you who support your
decision and will support you if you go
back or don't go back and do remember
that you're really risking finishing
your career because it's very very
difficult at least in my experience to
want to return after doing this but yeah
this was the video i
i did not realize i did not think it
would be so long i thought it would just
be a short little no i don't regret it
it was great this is the reason and it
turned into a huge rant so thank you for
bearing with me honestly if you made it
so far and thank you for sending in all
your questions i hope you have a
wonderful rest of your day be kind to
yourself and others and don't believe
everything you think thanks bye